i'm here at the olympic village in tokyo
and this is where around 18 000 athletes
and officials will be staying during the
games
but the concern is that there could be a
super spreader event at the olympics
it's raised a huge logistical challenge
for the organizers
you can't really create a kind of bubble
situation for the olympics
so what they're doing is they're
creating controlled zones where they
don't want people
to leave
[Music]
controlling people and making sure that
they follow various rules
will be a huge challenge so we are going
to see
how the organizers plan to make sure the
world's biggest sporting event during
the pandemic doesn't become a covered
hotspot
[Music]
so this is where the athletes are going
to be eating of course the dining area
is one of the places at the
olympics where people like to socialize
normally but that's one thing that the
organizers want to avoid it's a
potential
hotspot for virus transmission so most
of the athletes will be eating by
themselves
this is the fitness center and there's
special precautions here as well of
course
the organizers here say that they will
be asking athletes to wear masks
there's quite aggressive air circulation
as well but the machines are very close
together so
this is a place where they are saying
that if
athletes come and it is very busy they
will be turning them away at the door
[Music]
these are the condominiums that the
athletes are going to be staying in here
in the village and you can get up to
eight athletes in one apartment
this is an event that's spread all over
the country it's all around the greater
tokyo region
it's even 500 miles away in hokkaido in
the north where the marathon is going to
be held
so the goal is to create this kind of
archipelago
of controlled zones across japan when
people travel between the village say
and the olympic stadium or other venues
they'll be dedicated
bus and taxi links there will be
punishments that will be
imposed on people that go into the city
the organizers even said that they want
people to
have the gps tracking function turned on
their smartphone when they come in
the organizers have come up with some
very strict
rules about what people can and cannot
do
in general in in japan people do follow
the rules
but there's some concern here in japan
that people coming from overseas will be
a bit more cavalier
so you have quite a large movement of
people around
and that's a challenge to make sure that
those people
don't spread the virus amongst each
other
and that we don't have a sharp increase
which could put the olympics really into
crisis